apple vient d'enterrer son iPhone mini
ça y est c'est fini il y aura plus
d'iPhone mini on retrouve à la place un
iPhone 14 6,1 pouces un iPhone 14 plus
6,7 pouces et puis dans les modèles pro
un iPhone 14 pro 6,1 pouces également et
un iPhone 14 pro max 6,7 pouces
également un truc est très surprenant au
niveau de la dénomination je m'attendais
est-ce qu'on a un iPhone 14 max oui
d'abord un iPhone 14 plus la
dénomination plus on l'avait sur
l'iPhone 8 8 plus et on l'avait
complètement perdu par la suite donc on
a un iPhone 14 14 plus 14 pro 14 pro max
je sais pas ce que vous pensez de ces
dénominations dites-le-moi en bas dans
les commentaires et puis pour tout
savoir de l'actech je vous invite à lire
vous abonner